allocution de monsieur Étienne
cardilles conjoint du capitaine de
police Xavier
jugelé
Xavier jeudi matin comme de coutume je
suis parti travailler et tu dormais
encore nous avons échangé au fil de la
journée sur notre projet de vacances
dans un pays si lointain que tu m'avais
dit très impatient et que tu n'avais
jamais été aussi
loin les détails de visa nos
préoccupations d'hébergement envissaient
nos messages d'une frénésie d'autant
plus joyeuse que nos billets d'avion
étaient réservés depuis
mardi tu as pris ton service à
14h dans cette tenue de maintien de
l'ordre dont tu prenais tant soin parce
que ta présentation devait être
irréprochable tes camarades et toi
avaient reçu la mision la mission de
rejoindre le commissariat du 8e
arrondissement vous deviez comme si
souvent assurer la sécurité du public
sur cette belle avenue des
champ-élysée on t'a désigné comme point
de stationnement le 102 avenue
deschanélisé
devant l'Institut Culturel de
Turquie ce type de mission je le sais te
plaisait parce que c'était les champs et
l'image de la
France parce que c'était aussi la
culture que vous
protégiez à cet instant à cet endroit le
pire est arrivé pour toi et tes
camarades
un de ces événements que chacun redoute
et dont tous espèrent qu' n'arrivera
jamais tu as été emporté sur le cou et
je remercie ta bonne
étoile tes camarades ont été blessés
l'un d'eux gravement ils se remettent
progressivement et nous en sommes
soulagés tous sont été
choqué je suis rentré le Soirans
toi avec une douleur extrême et
profonde qui s'apaisera peut-être un
jour je
l'ignore cette douleur m'a donné le
sentiment d'être plus proche que jamais
de tes camarades qui souffrent comme toi
silencieusement comme moi
silencieusement et pour ce qui me
concerne je souffre sans
haine j'emprunte cette formule Antoine
leris dont l'immense sagesse face à la
douleur a tant fait mon admiration que
j'avais lu et relu ces lignes il y a
quelques mois c'est une leçon de vie qui
m'avait fait tant grandir qu'elle me
protège
aujourd'hui lorsque sont parus les
premiers message informant les Parisiens
qu'un événement grave était en cours sur
les ChampsÉlysées et qu'un policier
avait perdu la vie une petite voix m'a
dit que c'était
toi et elle m'a rappelé cette formule
généreuse et guérisseuse vous n'aurez
pas ma haine
cette haine Xavier je ne l'ai pas parce
qu'elle ne te ressemble pas parce
qu'elle ne correspond en rien à ce qui
faisait battre ton cœur ni ce qui avait
fait de toi un gendarme puis un gardien
de la paix parce que l'intérêt général
le service des autres et la protection
de tous faisait partie de ton éducation
et de tes convictions et que la
tolérance le dialogue et la tempérance
étaient tes meilleures
armes parce que le policier derrière le
policier il y avait l'homme qu'on et
qu'on ne devient policier ou gendarme
que par choix le choix d'aider les
autres de protéger la société et de
lutter contre les
injustices cette mission noble que la
police et la gendarmerie assurent et qui
sont régulièrement mis à mal moi en tant
que citoyen avant même de te connaître
je l'admiraai
déjà cette profession de polici est la
seule à laquelle la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen face
allusion dans son article 12
elle é dicte cette
évidence la garantie des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen nécessite une
force publique avec une précision
utile en cette période politiquement
importante cette force est institué pour
l'avantage de tous et non pour l'utilité
particulière de ceux auquel elle est
confiée c'était la vision que nous
partagions de cette profession mais une
facette seulement de l'homme que tu
étais l'autre facette de l'homme était
un monde de culture et de joie où le
cinéma et la musique prenaient une
immense part cinq séances de cinéma dans
une magnifique journée en souleillé
d'outt ne te faisait pas peur et bien
entendu les versions originales étaient
privilégiées pour le puriste que tu
étais et pour cette langue l'anglais que
tu voulais parler à la
perfection tu enchaînnais les concerts
suivant parfois les artistes sur une
tournée complète céindon était t étoile
zasim Madonna ou Britney Spears et tant
d'autres faisait vibrer nos fenêtres le
théâtre te transportait et tu le vivais
pleinement aucune expérience culturelle
ne te faisait
reculer le pire des films était vu le
jour de sa sortie jusqu'au bout quelle
que soit sa
qualité une vie de joie et d'immense
sourire où l'amour et la tolérance
régnait en maître
incontesté cette vie de star tu la
quittes comme une
star je voudrais dire à tous tes
camarades combien je suis proche
d'eux je voudrais dire à ta hiérarchie
policière combien j'ai vu la sincérité
dans ses yeux et l'humanité dans ses
gestes je voudrais dire à tous ceux qui
luttent pour éviter que cela se produise
que c ces événements se
produisent que je connais leur ilité et
leur sentiment
d'échec et qu'ils doivent continuer à
lutter pour la
paix je voudrais dire à tous ceux qui
nous ont témoigné leur
affection à ses parents et à moi que
nous y avons été profondément
sensible je voudrais dire à ta famille
que nous sommes
unis et à tous les plus proches qui ont
été si soucieux de moi qui ont éé si
soucieux de nous qu'ils sont
magnifiquement dignes de
toi à toi je voudrais te dire que tu vas
rester dans mon cœur pour
toujours je t'aime restons tous dignes
et veillons à la paix et gardons la
[Applaudissements]
paix